kyle you've been accused of racist
comments and microaggressions how do you
respond to that and how you work on
yourself outside of the house
yeah so there's no denying i made some
generalized thoughts mid-game that were
terrible and had no grounds for the game
of big brother the players in the house
were so open and understanding and i'm
so grateful for that and moving forward
it's now up to me
to find the resources necessary to
continue on this journey
now multiple times you brought up
concerns about another co-cut alliance
why were you so concerned without
evidence and do you feel like your
biases led to those concerns
i i just had some generalized thoughts
um again that were very unfounded and
had no grounds and
i definitely regret those those thoughts
and feelings and voicing those concerns
you know during the game
when britney brought up the optics of
the alliance you were pitching you seem
to double down on your proposed alliance
why was that
my closest relationships game wise i had
a final two with turner i had a alliance
of three with michael and brittany
called the
outsiders and then the alliance with
alyssa i basically had a final two so
within the game of big brother those
were my four closest relationships you
were part of the leftovers who were
steamrolling the entire competition why
did you betray them before you were even
on the block
i knew going out to dire fest that it
was either
me going home or joseph going home and
so i was definitely in survival mode
and i knew if i didn't come forward with
the information and joseph did then i
probably was going home that week so i
made the decision to
sacrifice the alliance and deal with the
consequences later and do you have any
regrets about choosing your showmance
with alyssa over the leftover alliance
early in the game i was prioritizing the
leftovers and not as much alyssa but
later in the game
my
thought process was all about alyssa so
i don't have any regrets um
i enjoyed every minute of my time with
alyssa
and